all of these women are Barbie and Barbie
is all of these women I feel like
everyone has a Barbie memory hi Barbie
hi Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie I have a
very little visceral memory of looking
at Barbie behind the box and that
feeling of wanting her shoes and her
hair to be perfect when you're little
when you're playing with your dolls
you're thinking God I wish it was real
why can't it be real
this is the best day ever it is the best
day ever and so is yesterday and so is
tomorrow and so is the day after
tomorrow and every day from now until
forever
when I was growing up I was a huge huge
fan of Barbie I inherited some from my
sisters so I had almost 30 Barbies not
to brag I definitely had Barbies
definitely make them make them kiss
why
I'm actually not sure
if I'm being perfectly honest Barbie was
not my thing
but now I love Barbie oh my God
I definitely remember making all my
Barbies weird Barbies and trying to
color on them and cut their hair it's
cool
there's just an immediate reaction that
people have to her and so we had to
create a world that everyone could see
themselves as a Barbie or could see
themselves as a can
foreign
[Music]